rumeur par humeur gwyneth paltrow va
donner des cours d'orgasme oui alors
absolument c'est quoi que nous dire elle
va il ya le teaser qui est parue du coup
s'il vous plaît vous rendre au mans du
coup si vous pouvez en prendre
vous ne vous inquiétez pas pour que ce
côté là ça va très bien avant et du cou
du coup elle va faire une série sur 6
aux états unis où elles valent entre
fable où elles vont expliquer comment
être mieux dans leur peau comment alors
par exemple il faut se mettre des
petites pierres de jade dans le vagin
pour aller très bien
il faut se forcer à sauter dans le vide
poches exorciser ses peurs bref il faut
boire du jus titre on se met de la
carotte pour être toute belle bref c'est
pile pour ces trois c'est totalement sur
ces trois femmes en famille pour qu'on
comprenne bien qu'il faut aimer non mais
c'est vrai ou non mais oui elle est
derrière le truc à elle court